election day has officially given way to
Groundhog Day that's right because
Maricopa County officials have told
reporters that we likely won't have
results in two of the most pivotal races
in the country the senate seat in
Arizona and the governorship of Arizona
until next week
now initially we were supposed to know
the results on Tuesday that's election
day then they couldn't do that some
machines were breaking some people they
couldn't count so fast
so then they said Friday you'll know the
results on Friday now looks like it's
going to be even later than that
presumably the delay is being caused by
supply chain issues in the delivery of
new ballots for Democrat Katie Hobbs I'm
joking I'm joking YouTube I'm joking is
that a joke I don't know the delay
though means that America remains a
laughing stock
if any other Nation on Earth took this
long to tabulate its votes
the U.S state Department would be
investigating that Nation for subverting
democracy here in the United States
however they tell us no that's business
as usual that's just the way elections
work now
and if president Trump's latest attack
on Ron DeSantis and Glenn Younkin is any
indication
we will be well into the 2024
presidential race before we know how the
2022 midterms finally shook out I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Jack straw who
says the only surprising thing about
Trudeau's appearance on that drag show
is that he wasn't in drag I know that's
true that's going to be the next step
obviously because you know people always
have to one-up one another when it comes
to these kind of religious political
rituals and we know Justin Trudeau likes
costumes already so if he can wear a
black face he can wear a woman face and
that maybe that'll be for his next
election maybe that'll be when he runs
for U.N Secretary General or something
like that the rest of us though I think
we need a little more red meat you know
I think we need a little bit more iron
pumping in our blood a little more
strength that's why you got to check out
good ranchers right now head on over to
goodranchers.com Knowles you know I love
spending the holidays with my family and
one of the ways I like to do that is
with delicious meat from good ranchers
as a special gift to our listeners this
holiday season good ranchers is giving
away two Black Angus New York strip
steaks free with your order these are
two 12 ounce Steakhouse quality Cuts
that's a seventy dollar value for free
you don't want to miss this offer let me
tell you why Black Angus tastes better
and is more tender than any other beef
black angus meat is marbled in such a
way that the fat is distributed thinly
and evenly this marbling gives it a
consistent flavor that you don't get
with other meats plus the Black Angus
from good ranchers is hand cut and
trimmed by expert butchers so you know
every piece is going to be Exquisite
while grocery store meat prices are on
the rise good ranchers is dedicated to
helping you save as much as possible if
you subscribe good ranchers today you
can lock in your price and avoid these
insanely high prices at the grocery
store and get some free meat while
you're at it go to goodranchors.com
Knowles use code Knolls at checkout for
this special offer that is
goodranchers.com Knowles for two Black
Angus New York strip steaks with your
order for free good ranchers American
Meat delivered 2024 is on NBC News is
reporting that Donald Trump is in fact
going to announce that he's running for
president on Tuesday at Mar-A-Lago I
spoke yesterday to a former senior Trump
official and a man who's still friends
with President Trump he says it is
etched in stone
Donald Trump is running it's not a fake
out still could be a fake out but
everyone around Trump seems to think
this guy is running for president
how do we know that it seems that he's
running for president well because he's
attacking
his rivals
I was gonna read his attack on Ron
DeSantis first he's got another attack
on Ron DeSantis first though I gotta get
he's got one on Glenn youngin
so Glenn yankin the governor of Virginia
Trump tweets out this morning
young kin two words now that's an
interesting take sounds Chinese doesn't
it in Virginia couldn't have won without
me I endorsed him did a very big Trump
rally for him telephonically
what
got Maga to vote for him or he couldn't
have come close to winning but he knows
that and admits it besides having a hard
time with the Dems in Virginia but he'll
get it done
so this actually isn't just completely
random this is in response to people in
young and World saying that Trump
actually was going to be a drag on them
and they were hoping that he wouldn't
come to a rally and they fear that if he
did a rally that would actually throw
the race and so Trump has to come out he
says I did a big rally for him
telephonically
what amazing diction a big rally on the
telephone
and uh besides you know he'll get it
done though no big deal and then that
opening young Kim that's an interesting
take sounds Chinese doesn't it
you have to admit that is an interesting
take
that is in fact an interesting take and
then of course Trump is reserving most
of his ire for Ron DeSantis so he's been
attacking DeSantis now since just before
the midterms calling him Ron de
sanctimonious then he went back to
endorsing Ron DeSantis for re-election
then the attacks Ron DeSantis
immediately immediately thereafter and
now he's just unloaded on him
this is the statement he released it
again on Truth social then sent it out
as a press release
statement by Donald J Trump 45th
president of the U.S News Corp which is
Fox The Wall Street Journal and the no
longer great New York Post bring back
call is all in for governor Ron de
sanctimonious an average Republican
governor with great public relations who
didn't have to close up his state but
did unlike other Republican Governors
whose overall numbers for a republican
were just average middle of the pack
including covid and who has the
advantage of sunshine where when I when
I yell by the way it's because it's in
all caps where people from badly run
States up north would go to no matter
who the governor was just like I did Ron
came to me in Desperate shape in 2017.
he was politically dead losing in a
landslide to a very good agriculture
commissioner Adam Putnam who was loaded
up with cash and great poll numbers
Ron had low approval bad polls and no
money but he said if I would endorse him
he could win I didn't know Adam so I
said let's give it a shot Ron when I
endorsed him it was as though to use a
bad term a nuclear weapon went off years
later they were the exact words that
Adam Putnam used in describing Ron's
endorsement he said I went from having
it made with no competition to
immediately getting absolutely clobbered
after your endorsement I then got run by
the star of the Democrat Party Andrew
Gillum who was later revealed to be a
crackhead by having two massive rallies
with tens of thousands of people at each
one I also fixed his campaign which had
completely Fallen apart I was all in for
Ron and he beat Gillum but after the
race when votes were being stolen by the
corrupt election process in Broward
County and Ron was going down 10 000
votes a day along with now Senator Rick
Scott I sent in the FBI and the U.S
attorneys and the ballot theft
immediately ended just prior to them
running out of the votes necessary to
win how long does this tweet thread go I
stopped his election from being stolen
and now Rhonda sanctimonious is playing
games the fake news asks him if he's
going to run if president Trump runs and
he says I'm only focused on the
governor's race I'm not looking into the
future well in terms of loyalty in class
that's really not the right answer this
is just like 2015 and 2016 a media
assault collusion when Fox News fought
me to the end until I won and then they
couldn't have been nicer or more
supportive The Wall Street Journal loved
low energy Jeb Bush and a succession of
other people as a rapidly disappeared
from sight finally falling in line with
me after I easily knocked them out one
by one we're in exactly the same
position now they will keep coming after
us Maga But ultimately we will win put
America First and
make America great again
wow that was a long one
that was a long one there was a lot in
there
wow
people are Furious about this
people are Furious about these attacks
especially this one because this is just
a full-on guns blazing attack he's
doubling down on the Rhonda
sanctimonious nickname
he's saying that he used federal law
enforcement to go in and help in the
election which kind of might put him in
a precarious position if the Dems do
decide to indict him but in any case
people are Furious about this and
they're saying why why Trump why do you
have to be like this why we've got a
good Republican Governor he just won
re-election it's two years out from the
general what why
why are you attacking
Rhonda said why
guys guys
if
these sorts of antics
are the sort of thing that infuriate you
rather than sort of amuse you
you've got to find some other way to
spend your time than to focus on
National politics
the question that people are asking
right now they're pulling their hair out
they're saying why is the Republican
front runner in 2024 according to the
polls attacking his most impressive and
threatening rival
why it just doesn't make any sense of
course it makes sense are you serious of
course of course this is happening
but
well okay yeah I mean I guess it makes
sense in the polls and I guess it makes
sense in the you know but come on why
does it have to be like that it
shouldn't be like this
okay but it is like this this is
politics this is exactly what politics
is all right and people are accusing me
of Defending Donald Trump
they're saying Michael you know I'm I'm
like the only conservative pundit in
America at this point who isn't going
around passing out yard signs for Ron
DeSantis and I like Ron DeSantis I love
Rhonda Sanders I think the guy's a great
governor
but I'm the only I think I might be the
last pundit in America on the
conservative side who is not just you
know lambasting Trump constantly and all
in for picking a nominee for the 2024
presidential race two years out from the
race we haven't even finished counting
in the midterm elections and I think
guys
good grief
let the process play out you're telling
me that
I'm I'm defending Donald Trump
when I observe that the sun shines am I
defending the Sun
when I observe that the rain falls am I
defending the rain
Donald Trump is going to fight
to win the presidency again
that is a fact
it is a very very silly it is a waste of
your time and your blood pressure and
your precious life that you have that is
finite
to pull your hair out and Rend your
garments over that fact
that is happening
now you don't need to enjoy that you
don't need to be thrilled about that but
you really should accept that that is
happening and no amount of yelling or
whining or begging or pleading is going
to stop that
there's nothing that you can do there's
nothing that any of the other potential
2024 Republican candidates can do
Donald Trump is going to do what Donald
Trump wants to do okay
and many of us have really liked Donald
Trump and have really appreciated a lot
of his policies and really got a kick
out of his campaigns
we cannot pretend that we don't know
this we cannot pretend that we don't
know who this guy is I don't think we
can even pretend that we're not sort of
amused by it at least on some level I
certainly am
it's just a fact okay and in politics we
deal with reality we don't you don't
live in the pie in the sky in my ideal
world no this is reality okay so we're
in it why is the 2024 race started
because it is well why is Trump
attacking his Rivals because that's what
happens in primaries that it's happening
guys okay you can either you can either
scream and cry and you know give
yourself a coronary over it or
you can just sort of take it as it comes
and and laugh at the things that are
kind of funny and wait to see how it
should fight for your guys of course
fight for what you want
but we gotta wait to see how it shakes
that this is going to be two years of
this all right don't don't let it drive
you crazy in the year of Our Lord 2022
all right now we're going to talk to One
Another We're going to persuade one
another that's how primaries work and
when you want to speak to your friends
you got to check out puretalk USA right
now head on over to puretalk.com code
Knowles there is no reason zero reason
to pay Verizon ATT or T-Mobile over 80
per month for wireless Services when you
can get the same service on the same
network at Pure Talk for half the price
with pure talk you can get talk text and
data that is just as fast for just
thirty dollars per month those other
guys are making you pay for thousands of
retail stores that you don't go to perks
that you don't use and massive profits
to keep their shareholders happy Pure
Talk on the other hand wants to keep you
happy which is why they are invested in
a us-based customer service team it's
also why they give you so many more data
options because why would they charge
you for data that you don't need I love
pure talk I switch to pure talk because
I like supporting veteran-owned us-based
companies that have my best interests at
heart it takes less than 10 minutes to
make the switch and you can save an
insane amount of money as I am go to
puretalk.com enter code Knowles to save
50 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code Knowles for 50
off your first month
speaking of vicious political attacks
a man in the United Kingdom
has just launched a terrible physical
assault on the king of of England
King Charles III
but because the man who attacked him
is very polite like all British people
he didn't attack him with a gun he
didn't attack him with a knife he didn't
punch him
he threw some eggs at him
you can see in the clip it's on BBC this
actually gives me a lot of respect for
King Charles the guy throws an egg and
Charles this just extraordinarily
dignified stuffy old British man just
kind of gently looks to his side as the
egg poles doesn't blink doesn't move
doesn't Flinch at all and the guy keeps
throwing eggs at him terrible arm by the
way it doesn't hit him once but Charles
he doesn't duck this wasn't like George
Bush with the shoe in Iraq where he's
kind of ducking the shoes he just stands
there
and the eggs keep flying and Charles
just keeps you know where were you
shaking hands in the line it's very very
dignified and it's good it really makes
me think
one
Charles is a lot manlier and more virile
than I think people including myself
would have given him credit for but two
that's dignity
and you know American politics not very
dignified whatever else you want to say
about American politics
it is not conducive to dignity
and it would be nice to have a little
bit of dignity just a little little
smidge of it as much as we can possibly
have in this kind of eccentric country
of ours when you look at Charles doing
that you think that's
that that's quite nice I actually rather
I rather like that I wish that we had
people who would stand up straight and
not flinch you know and kind of keep on
keep on keeping on keep a stiff upper
lip as the British have now for the man
who egged King Charles uh this man's
punishment
is I'm not joking he's a 23 year old man
Patrick felwell his punishment is that
he can he can no longer carry eggs in
public
just like that one of life's simple Joys
taken away from him that's right no
longer can he carry eggs
in public but otherwise he's basically
off the hook it's fine no big deal
in this case
really you would have to say the
punishment fits the crime you throw eggs
at the king you lose your egg privileges
that's very good one of the problems in
the American justice system right now is
that the punishments don't seem to fit
the crime if you are a BLM rioter and
you threaten people's lives and you Loot
and you steal and you pillage and you
burn and you throw Molotov cocktails
you don't get punished at all
you get maybe a little slap on the wrist
if that Kamala Harris bails you out of
jail and then you go right back into the
street do the same thing you get
encouragement actually for your crimes
from the the libs but if you're a
conservative who let's say shows up to
the capital rotunda on the day that
they're certifying the election and you
have a horn hat on and maybe you take
some selfies with a lectern in the in
the Rotunda and maybe I don't know you
crack a coarse light
at the Capitol
you'll be thrown in solitary confinement
your life will be ruined
the feds will go after you with
everything they've got forget about
January 6th for a second if you have the
audacity to say that you don't want your
kid to be transgendered in the third
grade you will be called a domestic
terrorist you will be investigated by
the federal government you'll be called
a fascistic threat to our sacred
democracy
it's a place where in in neither case
for the left or for the right the
punishments don't fit the crimes
the the leftists need to be punished
much more harshly and the conservatives
currently are being punished far too
harshly
though there is there is a case here
that that just came out and no one's
really reporting on this but I think
they should speaking of people connected
to prince Andrew quite a segue
one of Jeffrey Epstein's Associates was
accused of doing all the creepy sex
stuff with the underage girls and he was
accused by the main accuser of Virginia
giuffrey
and he the whole time maintained his
innocence he denied he had anything to
do it and nobody believed him I believed
him actually and I gave him the benefit
of the doubt because I know him
personally and I I just thought he was
telling the truth that would be Alan
dershowitz the famed Harvard Law
Professor Alan dershowitz was and to say
Epstein associate is really actually
overstating it he was he was Epstein's
lawyer and every man is entitled to a
defense in this country and Alan
dershowitz has defended some of the
worst people on Earth he that's his job
that's his role in the justices he
defended OJ and so he defended Jeffrey
Epstein
he said I wish I never met Jeffrey
Epstein but every man's entitled to
offense and I was his attorney and I
don't regret it I don't regret being his
attorney
but when he was accused of doing weird
sex stuff with Virginia jewfrey he said
I didn't do it I didn't do it I have
never engaged in sexual misconduct you
know for all my other sins that's not
something I've ever done this woman is
mistaken it's not true she maintained
that it was true well
just this week she dropped her lawsuit
she dropped it again she dropped and the
allegations against Alan dershowitz she
said I have long believed that I was
trafficked by Jeffrey Epstein to Alan
dershowitz however I was very young at
the time it was very stressful and
traumatic environment and Mr dershowitz
has from the beginning consistently
denied these allegations I now recognize
I may have made a mistake in identifying
Mr dershowitz this litigation has been
very stressful and burdensome for me and
my family and we believe it is time to
bring it to an end and move on with our
lives
now some people who are more cynical or
skeptical they'll look at this and say
ah but dershowitz just paid her off
but dershowitz says he did not pay her
off he says that no no money has been
exchanged here
she is dropping the allegations and then
dershowitz says as I've said from the
beginning I never had sex with with Miss
jewfrey uh
I have nevertheless come to believe that
at the time she accused me she believed
what she said Miss jewfrey is to be
commended for her courage in now stating
publicly that she may have been mistaken
about me she suffered much at the hands
of Jeffrey Epstein
and so so
now Alan dershowitz is dropping his
allegations that David boys engaged in
an extortion plot
and in some morning words right it was
this whole complex thing they were all
just dropping it now
I thought if anybody didn't do it who
was connected to Jeffrey Epstein it was
Alan dershowitz not because he's not a
man not because he doesn't have red
blood but because that guy is just so
buttoned up that guy is just so smart
he's so disciplined I just don't think
he would have opened himself up to
something like that for and all of the
other considerations
as well
this raises a question here
why is it why is it
that we don't know
who actually did it
why is I mean I guess we can strongly
suspect that prince Andrew did because
they settled for reportedly millions of
pounds out of court
but why is it that okay dershowitz was
all in the headlines but now his accuser
says now I think I was mistaken
why is it that we don't have that little
black book
why is it why is it the keyline Maxwell
she's getting some slap on the wrist
and as part of her prosecution
we don't know who who was with Epstein
we know that this guy
we know he paddled around with some of
the richest most powerful people on
planet Earth but why is it that none of
the people who did have sex with the
underage girls why is it that they
haven't been held to account why is it
that we don't even have their names for
certain
this is the sort of environment in which
someone like Trump really thrives and
there's a little bit of an irony here
because Trump did know Jeffrey Epstein
because Epstein was a member of his Club
but there has been no serious allegation
that Donald Trump went to creepypeto
island or that he slept with any of
these girls trust me if there were any
evidence of it the Democrats would have
been running with this for six years it
doesn't exist Bill Clinton took dozens
of flights with Jeffrey Epstein on the
Lolita Express you don't see any of
those same kind of allegations about
Donald Trump nothing
but this is the sort of environment in
which someone like a trump will flourish
and it's it's even now as I think he's
burning a lot of political Capital with
people who would otherwise support him
in these attacks on Ron DeSantis and
Glenn young and everyone else this is
still an advantage that Donald Trump has
that the other guys don't
Glenn young and especially Rhonda santis
they are incredibly good skilled
politicians who are
doing really excellent things and who I
think have a good clear political vision
and who have a lot of political courage
and a lot of political competence and
all the rest of it
but the distinguishing feature here is
Donald Trump even still even after
serving a term as president is not
viewed as a politician he did not work
in politics
all the other guys who potentially could
run are politicians and they've been
politicians and that's their profession
and good for them I think politics
actually can be a perfectly dignified uh
profession if one does it the right way
maybe that's a rare case but it
certainly can be but this is still
something that Donald Trump has and so
the more corrupt the more insane
the more nefarious that the political
establishment seems
the better Donald Trump looks and even
now even after everything that he has
been through
even after the bloom might be off the
rose a little bit that is still going to
be something that gives him a real shot
in 2024 okay for some people
it's going to keep them up at night you
know for something that's going to give
them a lot of stress but when you want
to sleep very well at night you've got
to check out Helix right now head on
over to helixsleep.com with everything
going on in the world right now you
could use a good night's sleep that is
why you need to check out Helix mattress
I have had my Helix mattress for what
two years now at least I absolutely
adore it Helix has several different
mattress models to choose from soft
medium and firm mattresses they've got
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep a little hot mattresses for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus sized sleepers are you
nervous about buying a mattress online
you don't have to be Helix has a sleep
quiz matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why would you want to sleep in
my mattress you know what don't answer
that okay sleep in your own mattress
make sure it's custom made for you go to
helixsleep.com Knowles take the
two-minute sleep quiz find the perfect
mattress for your body and sleep type it
will come right to your door for free
and then Helix has a 10-year warrant and
you get just right out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you're
gonna love it they've got over 12 000
five-star reviews it's absolutely
fabulous they've got financing options
make it super duper easy for a limited
time Helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is their best offer
yet so hurry on over to helixsleep.com
Knowles
speaking of
children
Eric swalwell
the the Former Future president The Man
Who Would have been president if he
wasn't one of the first people to drop
out of the 2020 Democratic primary Eric
swalwell
who infamously seems to have slept with
a Chinese spy Eric swalwell
thinks it's insane that you want to have
a say over your kids education Eric's
walwell tweeted out yesterday
this was in response to Tim Scott
Republican senator saying that we're
putting parents back in charge of their
kids education he says please tell me
what I'm missing here what are we doing
next putting patience in charge of their
own surgeries clients in charge of their
own trials when did we stop trusting
experts period by the way he didn't have
a question mark at the end of that
question just a period
that's from expert Eric swalwell this is
so stupid
so just
in point of fact
patients are generally in charge of
their own Medical Care
that they go out and they hire a doctor
they go and they find they consult and
they get different opinions and they say
okay maybe I'll have this surgery maybe
I'll have this procedure and clients
generally are in charge of their own
legal representation
they hire a lawyer or they represent
themselves but they're the ones
ultimately in charge
but this is what they think of you
this is what they think they think that
not only do you not have the right to
your
right to keep and bear arms not only do
you not have the right to free speech
not only do you not have the right to
make your views known in the Public
Square not you don't even have a right
to raise your kids
education means
raising raising up means leading Out
means
it's not just reading writing and
arithmetic it's the whole process of
forming a person of leading them that
comes from the the root for leading
and what Eric swallow is saying is you
don't have the right to any say in that
we do
I do I Eric swalwell who doesn't know
how to use question marks I Eric
swalwell I'm going to educate your
children
tell me what I'm missing here
if you don't have the right
some right
to educate your children
you don't have any rights
okay now that's not to say that you have
the sole right to educate your children
this I think is where conservatives go a
little too far this is where actually
Hillary
makes a point at least in the title she
chose for one of her books even though
she is perverting and misusing the
aphorism that she is borrowing
it does in fact take a village to raise
a child
children are not only educated by Mommy
and Daddy children inevitably are
educated by their Community that's just
what happened kids are just sponges they
take in everything if something's on the
TV that's going to be educating your
kids
if if they're hearing something from
their friends in the neighborhood that's
going to educate the kids
if they're paying any attention
whatsoever in school
that's going to educate your kids kids
are just
sucking in information and behaviors and
a moral View and a whole perspective on
the world all right and so
we need to defend our right as parents
to have some choice in the matter but
that's not enough we actually have to go
further and wield political power as
people like lanyonkin and especially
Rhonda Santos have done wheel that
political power to
force a certain type of education on the
political Community we have to force it
we have to coerce it I know that
conservatives sometimes are afraid of
using those words but all education is
coercive it that's what education is
when when the teacher says Johnny do
your homework or you get a bad grade
Johnny repeat after me you know the the
American Revolution began in 1776 that's
a fact you have to repeat that fact and
if you don't repeat that fact then
you're going to get detention
education is coercive it has to be and
there's it's a paradoxical because the
purpose of education is to liberate
oneself from the base passions and from
our sort of
slavishness that we're born into in this
world of sin and death and to bring our
base appetites under a line and and into
Accord with our rational will and to to
this is why we call it the liberal arts
right to make sense of our freedom and
to use it in a way that is edifying and
not debasing and not licentious so
that's the purpose of it but in order to
do that we have to be coerced and
there's only so much time in a classroom
and there's only so many days in the
school year and so you've got to make
choices about what to teach every minute
that you're teaching Maya kababi
genderqueer you are not teaching
Shakespeare or civics or the Bible I
guess we're not allowed to teach the
Bible anymore or anything else that
would be edifying so you've got to say
no Maya kababi no genderqueer no
critical race Theory we are Banning that
from the classroom we are wielding the
power of the state to coerce that out of
the classroom yes to Shakespeare and
math and science
and true history and all the rest of it
we have to do that now private lives yes
in our political lives as well the
Republicans who get that are the ones
who are going to be successful speaking
of young people
NBC
has sounded the alarm you see there's
this new show New Amsterdam
and I'm not going to play through the
whole clip of this but it's this whole
long intro to this sort of medical drama
of of all these doctors running through
the hallways and they look up and they
say they see the news and they're all
terrified and they're worried and these
men especially they're so worried and
they're so scared and they're so no no
and what is it at the very end of this
trailer they're looking up on TV and it
says Roe v Wade is overruled
it's so great it's especially creepy
when it's men who do this sort of thing
and it's it's so silly because you say
half the country is pro-life why what
the the TV networks don't want to get
half the country to watch their show
but that is educational
that is people watch that I was probably
more comprehensively educated by NBC
must see TV when I was a kid then I was
in my public school
all right so we need to wield
some control you know when Kerry Lake
the other day I hope she becomes the
governor of Arizona
you got to see if Katie Hobbs is able to
import enough ballots you know in time
by next week to see to see who wins that
race but Kerry Lake she said
when she was lambasting the media one
time she said we're going to reform the
media
and all of the squishes they said oh my
gosh that sounds so authoritarian that's
so oh it's not authoritarian to insist
on standards and to insist on truth
and to insist on a coherent edifying
good view of the world that's not
authoritarian okay the media
educates right it all plays a role
together
the very fact that conservatives in
recent years have drawn this clear
distinction between the public and the
private you know the government and the
private sector and the politics and the
culture as though those two things
weren't virtually synonymous no there's
just totally separate and politics bad
and we can't do anything in politics but
culture that's where we do everything it
the the fact that we drew these silly
distinctions and then conceded
virtually everything because of some
misguided
pretense of libertarian virtue or
something uh that's why we lost
and the candidates who really rise to
the fore in recent years they have been
the ones who are willing to wield
political power and I promise you
whoever gets that nomination in 2024
whether it's DeSantis whether it's Trump
whether it's younken whether it's
someone that we haven't even heard of
yet because don't forget folks it's two
years out before you pull all your hair
out
the the candidate that's going to
rise is going to be the candidate who
says yes if you give me political power
I will wield it
you know there's a great show out on
daily wire right now it is called on
marriage the exclusive three-part series
from Jordan Peterson it's on daily wire
plus uh I I think every single day I'm
truly blessed by God to have a wonderful
wife and two little kids with marriage
rights at an all-time low in the United
States and a birth rate that is
continuing to fall
everyone needs to watch Jordan's show
especially young people statistics are
also showing that young people are
getting married much later in life less
frequently too now our audience is not
filled with Peter Pan's but just in case
there's a few stragglers who are late to
marriage and family consider this a
pleasant kick in the teeth stop being
selfish for those of you married folks
who've let time and work and outside
forces get in the way Jordan will also
show you how to navigate through those
moments and get back to that romantic
fun adventure you had at the beginning
daily wire Plus members can watch all
three episodes of Jordan Peterson's on
marriage today if you're not a member go
to dailywire.com Knowles and join today
remember your membership really helps us
prevent the total collapse of society as
we know it if that's not an inducement
to join I don't know what is
finally we have arrived at my absolute
favorite time of the week
when I get to hear from you in the
mailbag our mailbag is sponsored by
puretalk at puretalk.com select a plan
enter promo code Knowles to get 50 off
your first month first question up in
the voicemail bag take it away
hi Michael I recently had a very
negative interaction with one of my
friends about abortion
we argued about it and we had kind of
haven't talked to each other since she
met all the classic arguments about uh
how women
should be in control of their own bodies
and how women will die if they don't get
abortions and women are going to get
thrown in jail for miscarriages all the
classic arguments
and I tried to go on with a scientific
argument even though I'm a Christian I
know she would immediately dismiss my
arguments outright if I used a religious
argument
what I wanted to ask was what would you
say to someone like that and how could
someone who is a Christian argue with
someone who's not a Christian about this
issue love the show thanks
great question
I break with many of my other
conservatives here a lot of
conservatives say well I'm I'm just
going to make a secular argument for you
I'm going to make a rationalist argument
for for such and such issue
because that's more likely to persuade
the libs
I just don't think that's possible you
can't make
really any argument
that is coherent and logical by taking
God out of it God is the logos God is
the defined Christ is the Divine logic
of the universe so in the beginning was
the logos and the logos was with God and
the logos was God
and so you're not going to you're not
going to make sense if you take God out
of it you can't make a secular argument
against abortion that is ultimately
convincing
what because what's the argument
the argument against abortion is that
human life
has value
and therefore we shouldn't kill innocent
human life
why does human life have value human
life has value because man is made in
the image and likeness of God
and because
even furthermore because God so loves
the world and God so loves us that he
gave his only begotten son such that
those who believed in him might not
perish but have everlasting life and
they sent his son to to suffer and die
on a cross and to be resurrected on the
third day and to redeem mankind so
that's it that's why and and you can try
to beat around the bush and say well you
know because of Human Rights okay why do
humans have rights well you know because
I don't know because the UN told me so I
don't know why do humans have rights
humans have rights because
I don't there's a natural law
well because we're made in the image of
likeness of God and because there is a
natural law well who gives us the
natural law God gives us the natural law
and the fact that there is a natural law
means that we can deduce certain facts
about the world certain moral realities
without necessarily turning to scripture
and revelation
but you're not going to do it
by denying God it's just it's just not
possible it's a Fool's errand and so I
would just confront head on I don't
think you need to accept the ridiculous
and false premises of the left well okay
let's accept your premise that God
doesn't exist and we're all just a bunch
of Meat Puppets and we're going to take
a dirt nap someday and turn to worm food
granted all of that here's why
abortion's wrong well granted all of
that abortion is not wrong because
nothing's wrong because nothing means
anything so no stick with your premises
and convince convince your friend of
reality don't don't pretend that
the the most important foundations of
everything that exists just you know
doesn't matter it doesn't exist next
question
hello Smokey Mike this is Julia your
number one fan girl I have no idea who
that guy from last week is but I'm your
actual number one fan
so anyways a little bit of background
before I ask my question one of my
friends who happens to be a fan of yours
has been really making fun of me because
I like to read young adult fiction I
like to watch the old Pixar movies like
Monsters Inc I really just find them
entertaining and I know that there's not
going to be anything weird or gross in
them
um so I was just wondering
um is it okay for me to like these
things and to admire them and kind of be
entertained by them in moderation or do
you think that's
um me kind of regressing like the
weirdos who get adult happy meals and
the women who are bawling their brains
out all emotionally invested in some
kids movie
um love to hear your thoughts
um have a nice day
Julia it is wonderful to hear from you I
am so glad for those listening I know my
self-described number one fan and so I
say this
in a spirit of great love and respect
it is regressing
it is there was a great quote I was
reading last night in a book by Owen
Barfield one of the sort of forgotten
inklings who C.S Lewis described as I
think his most important friend and I
think the man who helped convert him to
Christianity and he said after
adolescence
the only alternative to maturity is
plurality
that after you age out of the demo that
Pixar movies are are made for after that
your only Alternatives your only choices
are to kind of
grow up and do the adult things or to
regress and to see not childlike as
children do but childish now that said
I've seen some Pixar movies in recent
years okay they're Charming they're
wonderful movies
but the context in which I've seen them
is that I've I've seen them with my
children
and so this is one of the little hacks
if you have Nostalgia as all of us do
for things from our childhood and you
they make you feel comforted and they're
very nice and they bring up fond
memories for you you can go back to them
you can relive them in a certain way
but the way to do that is through your
own children and and really with your
own children
if you do it by yourself
it that's no bueno that that's
that's
odd but if you do it with your children
and it's a wonderful thing or if you
don't have kids yet which you don't then
you know it could be with your nephews
or your nieces or I don't know the youth
group that you lead or something like
that so I'm not saying that you you have
to completely shut those things out from
your life but you have to have an
appropriate relation to those things
you know I I let let's say someone
really enjoyed 10th grade you know I
don't know they just really 10th grade
for them was great and they love going
to homecoming and they liked I don't
know whatever the pep rallies
well when you're 25
you can't go back to 10th grade you
could become a high school teacher and
in a way then you get to you know be
reminded of that Nostalgia and live some
of those things again but you're in a
new position you have new
responsibilities and you have a new
Vantage so that's that's the way I would
recommend it because after adolescence
the only alternative to maturity is
plurality next question
hey Michael uh got very excited when you
started playing Dominick the donkey the
other day I am an Italian from
Connecticut so I play that song year
round but I agree with you generally
that Christmas music should be preserved
for close to Christmas I've leaned
towards December 1st anyways my question
is regarding kind of environmentalism
now I adopted your wording of the sun
monster and you know all of their
predictions are incorrect about climate
change and global warming and polar
bears dying
but I do when I drive around mostly blue
inner cities see trash everywhere and I
think there is a difference between you
know pollution and environmentalism and
the climate change alarmism so I was
wondering if there's a way that
conservatives could balance the two
where we actually care about the Earth
but also you know
shoo away climate change as being
ridiculous I'd love to hear or take
thanks Mike love the show
absolutely absolutely there are two
big mistakes that people can make here
and they're sort of in the opposite
direction One Is to worship at the altar
of the sun monster and and to fall into
all the radical environmentalism and to
destroy civilization in this attempt to
you know make Mother Earth happy
but the opposite error is to worship at
the altar of capitalism and say that
nothing matters other than ticking GDP
up a little bit and getting some more
greenbacks in your pocket
both of those are stupid reductive
materialist sorts of errors really what
we want is a good Society
and a good Society is uh needs a strong
economy and a good Society needs a nice
place I mean we need to have a nice
place to live and you want trash
everywhere
so that's what we want of course we want
to be stewards of our environment
uh for us because we are attending this
Garden of creation
we don't want to be
sacrificing ourselves on the altar of
the Delta smelt or something like that
so uh yeah it's very easy to do that
that is conservative I mean to conserve
nature the first conservationists were
conservative there's nothing
conservative about
trashing your community so that you can
add a few more zeros to your bank
account
but but there's also nothing
conservative about destroying
civilization so that the Delta smelt can
swim a little bit more as always
Prudence in moderation and and
recognizing where things are in their
proper place that we do not exist to
serve the natural environment but the
natural environment is here for us and
we are to be stewards of that
next question
hey Michael my name's John big fan of
the show listen every day
um I have a question I'm a
bible-believing Christian not a Catholic
uh but a Christian I hope you can for
forgive me and welcome me in but um we
talk a lot about god-given rights on the
on the right especially we really like
to cite those as a means for policy and
and whatever else that follows but I'm
just struggling with the idea of what
are god-given rights um where do they
come from where do we learn where they
are it's obviously not a very effective
argument to use against someone who
doesn't believe in God but aside from
that
um I don't see anywhere in the Bible
that it says God gives you these rights
and if someone violates them this
happens maybe I'm missing it maybe it's
interpretation based but I just want to
think about your thoughts on that I
think it's very interesting conversation
that nobody seems to have despite
everybody always citing human rights
when they want to get things done a
certain way thanks a lot certainly is
very interesting you'll notice that I
don't use that language very much it is
true
many probably most conservative
public figures
prattle on and on and on about god-given
rights left and right and the libs talk
about human rights left and right
because they don't believe in God
but I don't really use that language
because
that language comes largely out of the
Enlightenment and comes largely out of
the early days of liberalism and you you
say you know things that are called
god-given rights I don't really see them
popping up in the Bible or in the
Christian tradition and that that's true
I I asked or I I forget if it was me or
a friend of mine got to see we both got
to see Scalia when we were students and
one of us asked Scalia
do you believe in natural rights so
important to certainly at that time the
way that conservatives were talking
about the country do you believe in
natural rights
and he said I believe in the natural law
because the idea of
politics from the perspective of Rights
whether they be positive rights or
negative rights human rights or
god-given rights but the the whole idea
of politics from the perspective of
Rights is a liberal idea it's not a very
conservative idea the conservative
perspective is politics from the
perspective of Duty and obligation and
tradition and wisdom and Justice and
prudence
and so I think it would be much more and
I agree with you also just as a
practical matter those phrases are not
particularly uh persuasive we can go on
and on all day and say well I've got a
god-given right to free speech
whatever that means I don't even know
really what that means or the libs can
say I've got a human right to
I don't know chop off all my genitals
and make you pay for it and dye my hair
purple and do whatever you know but it
doesn't that doesn't really persuade
anybody the natural law however is
different because the natural law
from which we derive a concept of
natural rights but the natural law is
just the the moral reality that we can
perceive through the use of our natural
reason and our moral conscience and that
that is much more persuasive because
people know that it's wrong to commit
murder wherever you go doesn't matter if
they've read the Bible people just know
it's wrong to commit murder we know we
know that certain behaviors are just
wrong we have a kind of wisdom of
repugnance we have a a moral conscience
with which we are mercifully endowed and
so I think that perspective is going to
be much more persuasive now the rest of
the show continues now before we go I
want to thank all of our listeners
who've served this is Veterans Day
I frankly think daily wire should have
Veterans Day off except I still probably
wouldn't take it off because I would
want to I would want to join all of you
but that's really thank you so much for
your service I know many listeners to
this show have served lots of my friends
here in this building have served lots
of members of my family have served in
the military so thank you very much for
uh putting putting your money where our
mouths are and going out and actually
standing up for our country and
exercising courage which is not just a
virtue but the prerequisite for all of
the other virtues so thank you very much
have a good Veterans Day light up a
stogie uh for me I will certainly light
one up for you if I see any of you
around town tonight I'll I would be very
happy to buy you a drink and a smoke the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it okay because this is
fake headline Friday if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]